here at home a few downtown businesses
remain boarded up
this ahead of president-elect joe
biden's inauguration on wednesday
bianca holman shares why some shops and
restaurants are increasing security
measures
business owners plan to keep up this
plywood through wednesday's inauguration
in washington d.c the capitol is blocked
off with miles of fencing and soldiers
standing guard
major cities and state capitals across
the u.s are preparing for possible
violence ahead of president-elect
joe biden's inauguration the height and
safety measures are to prevent another
deadly riot like what happened at the
u.s capitol
on january 6. here in las vegas there is
barricade fencing and boarded up windows
at the foley federal building and in the
arts district these decorated window
coverings were put up in march of 2020
due to break-ins during the first
pandemic shutdown these precautions are
still in place
like at rebar and retro vegas this has
been a wild ride this past year so
unpredictable
i would hope that that nothing happens
and
but again we're preparing for for the
worst but
but hoping for the best stonebarger says
he would like to remove the boards
within the coming weeks
reporting in downtown bianca holman 8
news now